let's now not delay any further and get
into hey tree at mail this week is this
if this is your first week checking out
hey treat male here's a quick
explanation of what that is hey let's
face it we're only a couple of blood
moons away from a total homo fascist
takeover Patriot man written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom so this episode of
hatred mail is some kind of critique
about the election and my views on
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton I guess
sort of I've listened to it three times
and I still don't fully understand it
but maybe we can listen to it together
and try to make sense out of it take a
listen here's hatred mail for this week
honestly sir you are asking it is it not
possible for people to change their mind
years after they had a specific opinion
you ping little dweeb this woman has
completely changed how she was back at
the time that her rapist husband was the
president no she is even more evil and
more of a bomb guard you are a tip and
you have your head shoved so far up
Hitler ease bushy King evil tooth
machine it's not even funny good stuff
man you have completely made yourself
look like a feminist douche bag you [ __ ]
I guess the point is I'm a feminist
because I at some point said that Donald
Trump is a flip-flopper or something I I
don't totally get it
but clearly people very very agitated
and riled up about this election and I
will remind you I have two hatred mail
t-shirts these are one-of-a-kind items
these are items we were considering
offering on the David Pakman show
website two different hatred mail
designs both of these are size medium
and if you want one of the two and a 10%
discount off of membership you can use
the coupon code Patriot shirt at david
pakman.com slash membership